hey justin here with a gamespot news
update from pax east Blizzard has just
announced a single-player adventure mode
for hearthstone the adventure mode for
blizzards Warcraft themed free to play
card games planned for a really sometime
this summer and players will make their
way through a famous World of Warcraft
dungeon the floating necropolis of
naxxramas there will be five different
sections or wings of the dungeon to
battle through with one wing released
each week the first wing to be released
will be the arachnid quarter and it will
be the only completely free one
subsequent wings will require a purchase
of in-game gold or real-world money
although the price details have not been
announced each wing will also feature
new bosses to defeat and new cards to
earn Blizzard says there will be 30 new
cards added to the game through this
expansion you can add the cards you earn
to your decks for use in every other
game mode and they'll be added to the
pot in arena regardless of whether
you've played through the adventure mode
or not other editions coming with the
expansion include challenges that earn
the player new class specific cards and
a new spooky naxxramas themed game board
for even more news from pax east be sure
to stay tuned to gamespot com